hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
going to answer question from one of our
readers whose name is Fulton and he is
asking how can he market himself online
he sells life insurance so thanks for
the question a very common question how
do i market them myself online a lot of
entrepreneurs trying to get more
exposure increase their sales through
online and it's a great mechanism to do
it and you're in one of the most
competitive businesses and life
insurance so it's a excellent
opportunity to be able to stand out from
the crowd my number one advice in terms
of getting started online is if you
don't have a community yourself yet
that's a long-term strategy so we're
going to build a community around you
and being that expert on life insurance
but the first way to build that is to
try to find somebody who already has
your target market and partner up with
them so an idea here is look for people
who have a community they have blogs
they have a successful Twitter account
and offer to create content for them so
they have a successful blog maybe it's
not about insurance but it's targeting
your right market so I don't know what
you got the carrier in but if it's a
popular blog from a specific area then
maybe you can create content for them as
a guest post so instead of taking the
long road to building your own community
what you'll have to do in the long term
you're immediately tapping into somebody
else's community and providing them with
extremely helpful information so you
want to think about what value you can
provide and start pitching these
bloggers and other online communities to
provide them with that helpful
information so usually what really helps
here is you come up with a list of
potential ideas and you email them and
say hey I have a story idea for you
think it could really work here are a
couple of thoughts for you and again
just try to add as much value as you can
and do some research into the blog that
you're trying to reach out to write it
has to make sense for their community
and if they've written anything similar
before then make mention of that you can
say hey I noticed you wrote about XYZ
before and ABC before and I thought this
would be a good complementary post to it
so that's step 1 make a list of all
these different blogs you can outreach
to and offer to write some guest content
for the
and that'll start building up your
profile give you an immediate impact
because you're reaching a community of
people who already exist the next part
is creating your own community and this
is longer-term but can help you really
build a successful profitable online
business and hopefully you want to be
around for the long term so you want to
be able to have your own community so it
starts with your own website doesn't
have to be anything fancy just a simple
website make sure you tell your story
you know life insurance is so commodity
driven like everybody sells it it's it's
so easy to go and get that you have to
make yourself stand out from everybody
else and that starts with your story so
why did you get into life insurance why
is it important to you and don't just
copy and paste the stuff that you get
from your company and you know put on a
website and hope that it's going to work
you have to make it emotional make that
emotional connection with people maybe
make a video of yourself explaining why
you got into life insurance why you feel
is really important but have that true
story of yourself on your site so when
people read the guest posts that you've
created on another blog and come and
land on your site they can learn a
little bit more about you how you got
started why you're doing this and the
more time they spend on your site and
learning about you the more time and
more likely they're going to want to
sign up with you and buy your life
insurance products or at least ask you a
question
next is thinking about other content
that you can create on your own site and
through your own social media channels
and quite often this comes just from
questions so you may not have readership
yet you may not have a lot of people who
are on your website yet or following you
on Twitter on Facebook but you're
meeting people you're meeting prospects
you're meeting potential clients you
know meeting with clients and what you
can do is turn those questions into
posts and instead of being promotional
you want to think about how can you add
value if you add a lot of value people
will follow you
they'll spend more time on your website
and the next time they're looking at
barring life insurance guess who they're
going to want to call first you because
they like you to know you they trust you
they enjoy your story they think you're
an honest guy and they're going to want
to work with you so it's creating that
value add content so if you get
questions from people if you're meeting
with prospects you're an expert right
you know what you're doing this goes for
all entrepreneurs hopefully you're an
expert in what you do and you can answer
these questions inside out any day of
the week
for your prospects or customers it's
confusing it's scary they've never done
this before they have a lot of questions
and so if you can answer those questions
for them in a really friendly helpful
way then they're going to build a
relationship with you and want to sign
up for your services so when people are
asking you questions turn those into
potential blog posts turn those into
tweets turn those into Facebook posts
you might if you're you know adventurous
turn it into a video post like I did
with these ones here so just as a quick
example I used to get a whole bunch of
emails from people asking them to help
them with their business and I love
doing it that's what I do most of the
time I'm not going to pay for it I just
love helping entrepreneurs and seeing
them have some success I know hard it is
to try to start up a business and feel
like you're all alone doing it so if I
can help I try I used to answer those
emails just with an email reply and it
really helped that person always said
great thank you so much but then I
realized you know I'm only helping that
one person and chances are lots of other
people have the same problem in the same
question so I started making these
youtube videos as a way to answer that
person's question but also help a lot
more people so you know you're asking
how can I promote your your life
insurance business online but the same
advice can be used for anybody who's
trying to promote online so hopefully
I'm answering your question but also
everybody else who has the same question
Suki's do the same thing doesn't
necessarily have to be a video you can
work your way up to that I know it can
be scary and frustrating and doesn't
have to be too expensive but it's new
and time-consuming so you have to be
committed to it but it is a great way to
build up a connection with people they
can see your face and hopefully a big
smile and it builds that relationship
but start slow start at the beginning
start by making those partnerships with
other bloggers offering to create guest
content for them to start building up a
presence then have your own website that
tells your story is personal is
emotional explains why you believe
passionately in what you're doing and
then start creating your own content by
answering questions from your readers
and from your prospects and your clients
and sharing that with people so that you
become known as the expert to go to when
people have questions about life
insurance online so hopefully that helps
for those of you watching if you like
the video please give it a thumbs up
below it makes you want to do more these
for you and you have a question or
comment I love to hear we have to say if
you want to leave it underneath I always
read those and I try to respond as
quickly as I can so thank you and we'll
see you on the next episode
you